and white is completely paralyzed with
his king and the knight alone will not
make any headway black's bishop is
actually going to be a great defender
look at all of black's pawns on the dark
squares black's bishop is simply going
to defend those pawns when necessary and
at the very minimum i think we'll see a
draw from wesley so he's got full
control and white's knight is also going
to be stuck paralyzed blocking this pawn
wesley's just going to wait with the
black king and with the black bishop as
well and no way forward
dude frustrated what do you think ivanka
draw draw i don't think i don't think
wesley's going to even bother to try to
win this one it's just going to wait
around and say hey you're going to do
nothing yeah and the two experienced
americans are going to clinch these
blitz matches there we go it's a draw
wesley so takes the win in today's match
nakamura won his match too yeah it's uh
a good blitz tie break for the two
americans two points for a car and
nakamura against artemyev that one
actually ended in stalemate
and uh a loss in thai race for young
christoph duda against wesley's